You are listening to radiolab radiolab
from [inaudible].
W. N. Y. S. C. E. N. N. P. R. Alright.
Three two, one. Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. O.
K. I'm Robert Krulwich. You're
a cheery today. I was curious.
This is radio land. This is our podcast
version. Yes, and today on the podcast,
stay in that cheery frame of mind because
we're going to talk about pain today.
So here's the quandary.
It is really hard to put words to pain,
like to describe to somebody. I have
this pain in my back and it feels like,
wow, like odd or really hurting.
It's like it's really difficult
to describe to someone
in a way that would let
them feel it too. It's like one
of these classic empathy barriers.
Right? That's true. But if you
could quantify it, measure it.
If I could know exactly numerically
what you're going through,
maybe that would help. Maybe we could
be better friends if, if you could,
do you think you could is
that know Oregon to try?
See our producer,
Tim Howard over the last few months has
encountered three different people who
in different ways are trying
to measure pain, share it.
So we're going to do three episodes
of pain calibration calibration,
a triptych of pain
calibration. Okay. Bring it on.
You used to, uh, well
I got started with all this when I met
this guy. Yeah. I'm Justin Schmidt.
I'm a research biologist,
but he's really a bug guy.
I like to try to get into the
head of the stinging insect.
He lives in, in Tucson, Arizona, and um,
works in this one story building
on a residential street.
Right now we're in my
laboratory at southwestern
biological institute. Could we,
could we just, uh, take a quick
like glance around? I'd love to,
I'd love to just like what? No, no.
What it is though, we're looking at,
underneath those cabinets are
48 drawers of insect specimen.
So these are, wow,
he's got wasp that's a Poco and
it's a nocturnal wasp is terrifying.
This one here, different
kinds of weird foreign it.
That's actually a flightless
grasshopper. It's got a lot of ants. Wow.
There's some little furry,
yeah. Those are velvet ants.
They're huge of you pick up one
of these things and get stung by.
It's going to feel like, oh my
goodness. That could kill a cow. Okay.
So this all started for Justin back
in the 70s when he was a grad student.
And I just thought for a Lark, I took
a seminar course in entomology. We,
we had one entomologist in
the whole university. This
is of course in bug signs.
Yeah.
This was in Georgia and he was outside
one day in the field and he was trying to
get a sample of, um, harvest strand
harvests or in, what does that look like?
About a third of an inch
long. And they're bright,
pretty good sized ants actually.
And he was trying to get
one into a jar and uh,
I got stung by [inaudible]
the night I kind of,
oh, it's odd. It didn't
really hurt at first. Okay.
It sort of felt like
somebody was using a dental,
a syringe or really fine needles.
Slowly injecting a little bit of water.
It had this kind of Crystalyn feeling.
It wasn't an immediate pain. This was
a delayed thing. And so then I thought,
oh, okay. But after about a minute,
he started really hurting
[inaudible]
oh, this really hurts.
Is this really deep sort of visceral pain.
Something was going in and tearing out
your nerves and your muscles and your
tendons.
[inaudible]
what struck me was how dramatically
different this was from anything that I'd
experienced from a Bumblebee, honeybee
sweat, B yellow jacket paper was in.
Once the pain subsided, he thought,
man, I need to study that. Yeah.
You know, he had all these kind of
higher level science questions about,
you know,
evolution of pain and insects and how
different stinging in sex develops.
But the problem was, oh,
O k pain.
What do we do about measuring pain if
he was really gonna get to the bottom of
why one insect was more or
less painful than another,
he couldn't do that with
just words like more or less.
I need numbers with numbers. He
could do all kinds of research.
Not to mention it would make working
with other bug scientists just a lot
easier. And I started looking
into this and found out, oh,
this wasn't anything new.
Nobody really knows how to
measure pain because you know,
no two people feel pain the same way.
Some people I'm hired pain tolerance
than others. On the other hand,
that harvest rent was objectively way
more painful than anything he'd ever been
stung by. Oh yeah.
So Justin realized what I need
is a universal insects thing,
pain scale [inaudible] so Justin starts
traveling all around the world and he's,
you know, every time he hears about
a bug, especially a stinging bug, uh,
he goes looking for it and in
order to be stung by it, well,
I don't like pain. And so he says
he's not trying to get stung,
but it usually happens. And as far as
he's concerned, that's a good thing.
For example, I was petrified
of this. The SINICA,
which I call the warrior wasp a sneaker,
is this a black wasp with this metallic
sheen down in Central America and
they're known for this warning sound
that they make with their nest.
They have this big carton carton being
kind of paper kind of goes, yeah.
[inaudible]. Justin
was there with another scientist and
they're tromping through the jungle and
then they find a nest. Here we are this
nest and it starts to make that sound.
Well, sure enough,
we eventually got a kamikaze that
came out and nailed me. Wait,
where did this thing you kind of on my
forehead and I just sort of sat on the
stump and sir, Ooh, this really hurts it.
It hurt like a yellow jacket or a horn,
but it was just a whole lot more and
it kept hurting for an hour and so I,
you know, recorded what the
feeling was for this hour,
but you're sitting there in a stump or
something and your forehead is throbbing
and you're taking notes.
Well, what else can you do?
He talks about getting stung by something
that makes him hurt so much that he
just starts screaming and pain for like
an hour in lying on the ground because
that'll make the pain less I guess.
Then my left hands sitting here shaking,
it's trembling, you know, it's
going up and down and I say,
Oh darn your hand stop that.
Then with his other hand,
he's taking notes about exactly what,
how it feels this left
once you flapping away.
And I'm in any case, how
many times has he been stung?
He told me he's been stung by like 150
species and probably about a thousand
times and he's used all those
experiences to build up a scale,
which he could say is a five
point scale, zero one, two,
three and four zero being that's
essentially trivial and four being really
hurts. But wait, how does he deal
with the whole subjectivity thing?
Cause like your four is going to be
different in my fourth here's something
pretty clever,
which is that he took that one sting
that we pretty much all know and decided,
I mean he used that as a reference.
So I anchored it with the honeybee,
which is ouch, which I, you
can talk about with anybody.
Anybody who's been stung by a honeybee,
it also doesn't hurt too much
and it doesn't hurt too little.
So it's like a mid point. Exactly.
And a middle point in this case was
easier than a top or a bottom because I
didn't know what the top or bottom where.
There's no way to know where
the top or the bottom is.
So a honeybee was was that, and see,
give that a two two out of four the
prime meridian of pain and every time he
gets stung by a new bug, he'll ask
himself, is it more than a honeybee?
Less than a honeybee, about the same
as a honey bee, a whole lot more,
a whole lot less then it gives
that thing its own number. Big.
This 1.0 sweat like a
femoral almost fruity,
1.8 bullhorn occasion and a rare
piercing, elevated sort of pain.
Someone is fired. A staple into your
cheek. 2.0 bald faced Hornet. Rich Hardy,
slightly crunchy, similar to getting
your hand mash in a revolving door.
How three red harvests are
in bold and unrelenting.
Somebody is using a drill to
excavate your ingrown toenail. Huh?
This is his pain scale. Justin calls.
This is tongue in cheek first. That was,
you know, more fun. But yeah, these are
some of these things that he's measured.
And what's the, uh, what's the worst?
What's the top of the scale? Uh,
the bullet and
it sends excruciating waves of burning
pain that are undiminished for 12 hours.
And you get these
pulsations, you get this,
this pain crescendo that goes to
you just about wanting to scream.
It backs off a little
bit and say, say, ah,
you kind of give it a little bit of a
sigh or we leave and then it sends back up
and it keeps doing this,
these hills and valleys of ascending pain
and then decrease even the decreasing
to the lowest still hurts.
So this scale, uh,
works for him and he uses it to
communicate with bug scientists.
Yeah. Yeah. Wow. Well, all
right. That's kind of cool.
But I gotta be honest. I, I, this is,
I'm wanting more right now because I, uh,
I liked the scale, but I'm thinking
actually beyond bugs to like,
let me just put my cards on the
table, like childbirth. Okay. Like,
oh, okay. I know. But we talked
about the gap between like, uh,
to people feeling pain. And
being able to share pain.
That's where the rubber meets the road.
It's used in a lot of marriages
as a constant. You don't know.
You don't know what exactly.
Yeah. Thank you Robert.
This tame argues it the
way Carla uses it. Well,
I can't say that in another
recording. No, not at all.
It really never crossed my mind.
Carla, who is a very sort of understating
lady when it comes to this subject,
she'll be like, you have no idea.
You don't even begin to know what you
don't know about what we just went
through. Well that brings me
to my second store. Can I,
can I take it from the top for
this one? We go back a few years.
So where in 1948
oh
well who is this lady?
This is Paula Michaels.
She's a professor of the
history of medicine. I teach
at the University of Iowa.
And she told me this story that takes
place in New York at New York hospital in
1948 right. So there's James D. Hardy,
there's Carl t Jeff air
hardy handover doctors,
and they're trying to test drugs.
You know what drugs are going to be useful
to alleviate the pain of childbirth.
And in this period there's a whole
range of things that are being used.
What are some of the ones
that they're using? Well,
like more Phoenix Cupola mean.
Um, demerol is a big thing.
Nice and heroin, which to
me sounds completely crazy.
They play on crack too. They, they
would have, if they knew about it.
The problem is they want to be able to
test all of these drugs so that they can
use them in a standard way,
but they weren't actually sure how
much pain women were really in.
And I guess you kind of have to know
that in order to know how much drugs to
give them. Yeah. They had no idea. And
it was a source of a lot of debate. Yes.
One man Grantly decreed a British
physician basically said straight out,
it's in women's minds, not their bodies.
What childbirth is a
completely painless experience.
Entirely psychological in origin. Wow.
That is an incredibly bold thing for
Amanda. Say yes, that's Chutzpah.
Now Hardy and Java or
didn't take it that far,
but they wanted to get past the whole
messy psychological part of childbirth and
eliminate that woman's subjective
experience of pain from the calculation of
whether these drugs are effective or
not and how are they going to do this?
Well, their method is pretty crazy.
Okay.
They had this apparatus
called a doll Ramadan.
It was this little wood box that had
dials and knobs plugged into the wall and
then was connected by
a wire to another part,
what they called the exposure unit.
That was like a heat gun with an
aperture that can shoot out heat.
Then they got some volunteers,
some of them are nurses,
some of them were the wives of
obstetricians or other physicians,
all very pregnant and they told these
women, this might not be very pleasant,
but by participating you are going to
be making childbirth just so much better
for every woman to follow. That's right.
And the women were excited to help.
And then when the woman went into labor,
hardy and Java would show up bedside with
the dolor arbiter and they'd wait for
the contraction to finish.
And then between contractions
during that pause,
they take the heat gun and they put it
against the back of the woman's hand and
they'd say to her, all right, we
want to know about that contraction.
The one you just had. Yeah, we want
to know how much it hurt. Nate. Say,
is it more like a
one more like it?
And then the woman would respond because
B as closer. Then they would say,
is it more like B or more like c?
See maybe that was a way
of then saying, okay,
well that was a contraction of
three dolls dolls with the doll.
The Dole is their unit of pain.
They're their standard unit
that they use for everybody.
[inaudible] and so over the course
of labor, after every contraction,
they would repeat this
process. Same drill.
Is it more like a or more like bit again
a B and again beat one more like c and
again over the course of her whole labor.
So we on top of all the labor pains,
they're just cranking this
heat up and up. Yeah. Wow.
In the case of one patient,
Oh,
who insisted on going the distance at
pain intensity of 10 and a half dolls with
measured hardy and Java are
called this the ceiling.
This is the most intense pain
which can be experienced.
Second degree burns were inflicted upon
the hands of this patient by the four
tests made at levels than nine
dolls. Second degree burns. Yeah.
I mean I like what these guys are
trying to do, but wow, that is sadistic.
It seems totally twisted, but
it's in the name of science.
It's for a greater good. Uh Huh.
All right. So then the doctor is,
they took all of the data from all of the
women and they start going through it,
looking for patterns,
looking for things in common.
And then the most incredible part to
me is that they converted all that
information into a mathematical formula.
Doles of pain equals 10.5 minus 1.5
times contraction intervals in minutes.
What? Well,
so they're saying if you tell us the
amount of time between the contractions at
any point in our labor,
we can tell you exactly how much
pain the woman is in no more mystery.
There's no more wondering problem-solve.
The code is cracked and what happens? Uh,
this is a breakthrough sweep.
The medical establishment,
I'm guessing it doesn't, uh,
no other people could not achieve the
same results that they achieved using the
Deloitte, I don't know, like at the lot
[inaudible] using the dull ramen or
they were not able to achieve the same
results when other doctors tried to do it.
That formula didn't seem to apply
to the women that they looked at.
Shocker.
Obviously there's a lot of problems
with the entire approach that these guys
had, right? No. Yeah.
I mean, for starters,
they were trying to compare pain
in the abdomen to, you know,
like a burning sensation on the
arm. Yeah. I mean, that's a,
that's like a translation
problem. Yeah. Well,
I mean in my opinion there's kind of
a bigger translation issue happening,
which is in order to talk
about a pain you're feeling,
you need to be able to observe it and,
and kind of stand apart from it in your
own head, if that makes sense. Sure.
And when you hear women talk about the
pain of childbirth, my name is Sarah,
I'm in Sacramento, California.
We asked people to submit theirs
through the radio lab app.
And when you listen to
these different accounts,
my experience of childbirth pain was,
it sounds like there's a certain point
where everything shifts and one woman
said it was at about late [inaudible]
seven centimeters dilated and that's when
you like lose your mind and
you can't think you can't talk.
Suddenly the pain
becomes so great, so bad,
but there's no more reference point.
I just remember there's no more objective
distance making these noises that were
just on earthly. And in these submissions,
it's usually at this point in the
story where the woman neither just
draws a blank wow.
Or resorts to some crazy analogy.
I felt like there was a freight train
bearing down on my vagina
from inside my body,
and then I could almost hear it building
to come to [inaudible]. I felt like
I was being dragged out to sea.
That's when I actually
heard a couple times waves,
waves of pain. And it was
kind of like that for,
for Paula too. I turned very
much inward in a way that,
that made time feel like it stopped.
[inaudible]
I was drowning,
drowning in this lake of pain and there
was a horizon and when the contractions
were intense, I would swim
towards the horizon. This is Eula.
I'm Eula Biss. I'm a nonfiction
writer and she's our third pain.
Calibrator and for me,
you look kind of gets the closest at
finding a way to communicate pain.
If, if I could see you have a
relationship with pain, uh, when did that,
when did that start for you? Let's see.
About almost 10 years ago,
I think I was about 26 at the time.
Ula was a Grad student in Iowa and uh,
I just woke up one morning in the fall
and I had a terrible pain and the side of
my neck, upper back side of my
face, she had no idea what it was.
It was a burning pain with this
nauseatingly tingling sensation.
I've really never felt anything
else like it. And months past,
and it didn't go away and it was making
it very difficult for me to sleep.
It started to interfere with my
thinking too. I couldn't concentrate.
So one day she went to the hospital
and by this point she was a total mess.
So I was kind of teary and
shaking and I said, you,
you need to give me something to help
me with this. And so the doc said,
all right, well take a look at
this thing up here on the wall.
This is called the pain scale.
It had the numbers zero to 10.
At one end it said no pain at the other
end it said the worst pain imaginable.
And the doctor says to her,
okay, what number is your pain?
Ula starts to think about it. The
worst pain imaginable is kind of vague.
Is this the worst pain
you yourself can imagine?
Or is it the worst pain
imaginable on earth? You know,
this was around the time that I think
a man had died being dragged behind a
truck in Texas. And I, I remember sitting
in the exam room thinking about that.
And then I was trying to do
some rudimentary mathematics
if being dragged behind
a truck a to your death is the
worst pain imaginable. What,
what proportion of that
do I feel? And I thought,
you know, a third of that
seemed pretty significant to me.
So she says three, I
guess. And the is like,
all right. And he does some tests.
He tries to figure out exactly
what's going on, can't really,
but since she said three anyway,
he's like, all right, well, you know,
have some aspirin, go home.
And this happened a few times.
She wasn't getting any
better. So at a certain point,
she calls up her dad who's also a
doctor and she starts complaining.
I was telling him how
frustrated I was that, um,
the doctors didn't seem to be taking
this very seriously. And he said, well,
when they ask you to rate your
pain, what, what do you tell them?
[inaudible] and I said, I usually
say three. And he said, well,
there's your problem.
Her Dad tells her you should say
eight, even if you're not feeling it.
That's what you gotta say.
And Ula thinks, you know,
this is ridiculous.
Why do we even have a pain scale if
I'm not supposed to take the numbers
seriously?
And, um, he said, in part,
it's a tool that's meant to protect
practitioners because it's emotionally
difficult to have someone say to you, um,
it feels like someone's jamming a red
hot poker through my eyeball rather than,
I've got a nine.
But then he made a suggestion,
which I think is really clever.
He suggested one scale where
that would measure what you're
willing to do to get rid of your pain.
What would you trade for pain relief?
Would you give up your sense
of sight for five years?
Would you relinquish your ability to walk?
Did you come up with any
answers at that point? I did. I,
they were disturbing answers,
you know, when my father asked,
would you accept a shorter lifespan?
At that point in time I thought, yeah,
I would have how many years?
I was thinking I'd take
10 years off my life.
Wow. For me,
that was basically the first time
I felt like I understood her pain.
But you know,
I was 26 and life seems really long when
you're 26 now I'm in a much difference,
but my pain is not nearly
as bad as it was then.
So now I'm not really in
the bargaining mood anymore.
I bet. Like how about a bad haircut?
Would you take it really bad haircut?
A Mohawk?
Huh?
Okay. Yeah. Actually it would.
And these days you'll,
is kind of pessimistic about the idea
that we're ever going to really have a
useful pain scale.
At the end of the day, I'm not sure.
Pain is a quantity that is measurable.
Hmm.
Thinking that kind of bums her out
because part of me wanted to believe
in the project of quantification.
Y I, I'm not sure. Um,
I think because not believing
in it is a little bit lonelier.
The idea that we cannot feel,
cannot understand and cannot imagine
each other's pain is a really isolating
thought.
[inaudible]
by the way, what was her pain from?
Did she get a diagnosis? Well,
her doctor tried a lot of stuff
actually. They did a brain scan.
They checked for a spinal infection,
and ultimately he said, you know,
unfortunately, we, we don't
know what causes this.
We don't know how to treat it. We don't
know if it will ever get better. Um,
but we do know it's real.
And that was my final conversation
with him and he said, um,
good luck out there.
[inaudible]
thanks to producer Tim Howard, Justin
Schmidt, Paula Michaels, and you'll abyss.
I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert
Krulwich. Thanks for listening.